[Musique]
tu confrontés à une réalité un peu
complexe et que pour faire une série sur
le rap il va falloir trouver des
rappeurs qui savent jouer la comédie et
la première question c'est est ce que
c'est possible quoi pour être très
honnête
le déclencheur cela rencontre avec nous
ça mansaly qui joue le rôle de ma star
je sais ce qu'ils offraient demandant
tout ce que je suis ce que je suis un
acteur joue c'est un rappeur et j'ai
aussi auteur j'écris des ddd des titres
pour course aux artistes projet validé
c'était leur symbiose parfaite entre les
corps de métiers ont bien là je voulais
des gens qui soient pas forcément très
identifiable par le public autant qu
rappeur de manière à ce que justement il
puisse s'identifier aux personnages
je voulais pas non plus que ce soit un
rappeur connu qui soit le héros de la
série pour pas que ce rappeur vampirise
l'image de la série serge voulais pas
que ça devienne
la série de la crim la série de kool
shen la série de mignot puis surtout il
fallait qu'on est quelqu'un qui a une
crédibilité de rappeurs absolument
incontestable qu'ils soient
charismatique emblématique qu'ils soient
qui représente un rap rappeur
d'aujourd'hui quoi un million de
questions me viennent en tête mass start
et le boss du rap game chantant ta voix
dans lequel je connais ton parcours
parker tu sais que tu en as pris ton
thème en nous servant salé et screech
qui est le patron de demolition qui
travaille aussi avec franck sur la série
qui m'ont contacté pour savoir s'il
était intéressé pour faire le pour
participer au casting apache est arrivé
on essaie alors qu'on avait vu peut-être
de son mec et puis se passe un truc ex
mais qui rend bonne pièce il se passe un
truc et prend de la place
on commence à faire des essais et puis
là c'est moins bien que ben oui c'est
mon bien parce que parce que ce serait
trop facile d'être tombé sur un mec qui
était un rappeur d'exception est un
grand acteur
il parie que je français de me dire je
vais pas le lâcher quoi j'aime être sur
son dos on va travailler beaucoup
c'est ce qu'on a fait ça permet de
mettre les spectateurs dans un état si
tu es trop en kiosque ou aux spectateurs
dont il s'avère d'avis tu vois ça ça
permet de me préparer la tension pour la
somme d'après j'avoue que c'est ça le
travail que j'ai adoré faire parce que
j'ai j'ai pas l'habitude de ça même si
je travaille avec des acteurs confirmés
ça lui met la pression dans le salon
malgré le temps d'attendre puisque la
nuit va être longue
il vaut mieux opter pour la méthode
d'une crise et c'est très bête dès la
première je vais monter le curseur et je
peux gagner du temps à tout le monde et
moi jamais trop comme faisait ça t'as un
mec qui n'a jamais joué de sa vie et qui
te dit je suis ton gars je serai là à
l'heure que tu me dis j'ai faim dis-moi
comment je dois fois que parce que je
vais pas faire
le plan de la grue et la voiture qui
passe est un coup d'état en drapé 3
d'abord je vais je dis bien de te sentir
que mettre en conditions potentiellement
est un peu angoissé tu vois
prendre un peu ton souffle et pouf on
parle de la complexité de ce personnage
et il m'expliquer pourquoi c'est
important que les gens voient mes
faiblesses avant de forcément me voir
vainqueur qui réussit tout ce qui fait
c'était vachement instructif les c'est
vrai que ça a été un gros déclic pour
moi ce moment là et je me rappelle la
répète d'après je suis revenu c'était
totalement différent je pense qu'il
pourra vous confirmer et c'était
vraiment un beau souvenir tutorat liste
validée une création originale à
découvrir en avant-première en ce moment
sur my canal